this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the
november 29 2012 session in our series
on green technologies and transportation
I'm Richard Dasher I direct the US Asia
technology management center that
produces this series also want to say a
special thanks to Sunbridge partners for
additional financial support of this
series we'll have some refreshments
outside as soon as the session is over
we really hope that you'll stay and
enjoy the networking after the formal
part of the presentation so also want to
point out that today is the penultimate
session in our series of nine
presentations about green technologies
next week we have mr. lou thompson who
is a very senior consultant and advisor
for railway transportation he's a member
of the peer review panel that's checking
up on california high-speed rail and
he's going to be talking about what the
United States should learn from asian
high-speed rail projects so that'll be
the final session in our series before
that I'm delighted that we're able to
invite mr. Steve Center who is vice
president of the environmental business
development organization inside american
honda motors steve is coming up to be
with us today from los angeles and we
really appreciate your devotion of time
and effort right you know in the middle
of the los angeles auto show he was
interviewed by the national press there
yesterday and so we're very happy that
you could come up and take time to give
the presentation today steve is a
veteran of sales and marketing in the
auto industry he's worked for Honda
Motors for more than 20 years and before
that he's done things like run a chain
of retail auto what do you call them
dealerships so Steve is a veteran of the
business side of the auto industry but
two years ago Honda which has a very
strong and long tradition that Steve
will tell us more about in regard to
environmentally friendly automobile
technologies asked Steve to put together
this new business unit that would really
combine a lot of the different
technologies that are in different silos
in the organization so this is a very
interesting business organizational
problem that you see not only in Japan
but in the US but we're delighted that
we can hear about this new business unit
as well as learn more about Honda's
power of dreams I'll turn over the
microphone to Steve at this point thanks
for coming thank you thanks Richard and
good afternoon everyone first off let me
say congratulations on a terrific
football season especially your big win
over the Ducks a few weeks back now i
don't know if it's fair to call a top 10
team with three back-to-back 10-win
seasons the underdog but if i remember
correctly aragon playing for all the
marbles was a 21-point favorite going
into that game so maybe it's okay to do
that at Honda we tend to root for the
underdog as the smallest player and the
amongst the world's biggest automakers
honda has long played the part of the
underdog and in a similar way maybe it
sounds a little odd in that we're a
global company with 50 billion in annual
revenue but we're playing in a very high
stakes game and you have to spite a
relatively small size or perhaps because
of it Honda's found a way to harness its
maverick spirit to constantly innovate
pioneer and prosper in the face of tough
competition maybe no place more so than
in the area of environmental technology
today I want to share with you some of
our latest thinking
eat your innovation in the alternative
fuel area not only the vehicle and
powertrain advances for which Honda's
best known but also our thinking for a
smarter energy and infrastructure system
that will add new value to the
alternative energy equation and support
the broader adoption of alternative fuel
vehicles maybe you can tell by my accent
or maybe you can't but I've been on the
west coast now for about 35 years but
I'm a transplanted New Yorker and like
many others I've been concerned about
family and friends back in new york and
new jersey and everyone they are
struggling to recover from the
devastation from superstorm sandy and
watching this disaster unfold it
occurred to me that there's a role for
alternative fuel technology in
mitigating the impacts from these kinds
of disasters so I'd like you to imagine
for a moment that your home is cut off
from the grid and you've been told it
could take days even weeks before the
power comes back on now imagine you're
driving a plug-in or electric vehicle
that you could hook into your home into
your home's power system or supply
backup power to run your 52 inch TV and
chill the beers for Saturday's stanford
UCLA rematch for example that might be
good further imagine a utility
infrastructure system that was smart
enough to tell the same car when it was
optimal to recharge based on the grids
load or minimizing co2 emissions even
the level of renewable energy being
applied to the grid at a given moment
that's the kind of thing we're looking
at it Honda's environmental business
development office or EB do that I
helped to lead we created this new
division within our sales and marketing
operations about two years ago our job
is to look at the entire marketplace of
ideas and approaches to advancing
alternative energy technology both
within and outside of Honda to foster
new relationships and to identify key
ways in which we can bring Honda
unique technology and marketing
expertise to bear within honda we're
working to bridge the gaps between
multiple technology disciplines R&D
programs and marketing initiatives to
create a more unified strategy for
future technology deployment of course
the notion of environmental innovation
is nothing new at Honda and it certainly
predates my time at the company Honda's
legacy of environmental leadership takes
bet dates back to the early 1970s and
the creation of the CV cc engine that in
the Civic was the first to meet tough
new emission standards under the 1970 us
clean air act and to do so using cheaper
leaded fuel and without the need for a
catalytic converter just that of
curiosity how many of you have ever put
leaded fuel in a gas tank okay I thought
so that's about what I figured I don't
suppose you guys ever made your own mix
tapes either did you know okay things
change but the engineers who created
that marvel the marvel that was the
Honda CVCC engine had a rallying cry
back then and that rallying cry was blue
skies for our children and this embodies
their dream to help clean up the air in
cities like Los Angeles New York and
Tokyo and thereby improve the health and
welfare of future generations I'm going
to tell you two quick stories when I
grew up in New York I can remember
standing on Park Avenue one day with my
father looking downtown at what was then
the Pan Am building and you could only
see the bottom half of the building
because from the middle of the building
up was covered in black when I was a
child playing in the streets there you
couldn't have a white car because the
buildings were constantly raining ash
from the incinerators burning the
garbage there and
the late 70s when I moved to Los Angeles
to go to grad school I was downtown at
USC and I realized what people said
about the smog your eyes are burning you
found yourself short of breath and I
really couldn't see much of the
neighborhood until one day the Santa Ana
winds came up which come up from time to
time blew all the smog out to sea not
only did I realize they were skyscrapers
probably a mile from the campus but the
city was sound a surrounding by
beautiful mountains and I thought to
myself that's a damn shame 30 years
later you don't have those days anymore
really the air there's very rarely an
air quality alert day in Los Angeles the
air is clean you can see across the city
and I think in great part it's due to
the efforts to reduce automobile
emissions and the technologies that were
applied but that rallying cry powered
Honda's continuous efforts to reduce
vehicle exhaust emissions in the 80s and
90s resulting in a series of industry
firsts including the first vehicles on
the market to meet California's Lev you
love sulev and P Zev emission standards
a little translation there the Zeb's are
for zero emission vehicles but in the
labs are for low emission vehicles but
anyway this was significant and that the
early catalyst technology was both very
expensive and a major hindrance to
vehicle performance Honda solution back
then was to create a cleaner burning
engine and that flew in the face of
industry critics who claim that these
new emission standards back in the 70s
were practically impossible to achieve
and potentially fatal to the industry
and of course we know now that they were
entirely wrong our efforts to reduce
smog-forming emissions continue to this
day in fact today at the LA Auto Show we
released key new details about the
accord plug-in hybrid that will be
launching here in California and in New
York right after the first of the year
the new Accord plug-in will be the first
vehicle certified to meet carbs sulev 20
emission standard which takes the
lifetime smog-forming emissions over
150,000 miles of driving down to just 10
pounds now for some perspective our
first l EV vehicles produce somewhere
around 120 pounds of smog-forming
emissions over there for life cycle so
you can see by that the very great
distance so we've come and those words
blue skies for our children today remain
very much part of our world if you see
anything related to our environmental
efforts you're likely to find a tagged
with this Honda blue skies logo but
what's most important here is not the
branding but the spirit behind it at the
company now in respect we can say that
the original goal of blue skies has
largely been achieved and so our
environmental vision today is shifting
and is now centered strongly on energy
sustainability and the reduction of co2
emissions that contribute to global
climate change that vision is formally
expressed now in honda's environmental
vision statement as realizing the joy
and freedom of mobility and the
sustainable society where people can
enjoy life now that may sound a little
bit too philosophical but it captures
several key points about Honda's
approach to environmental innovation the
first is that Honda does not view itself
as an automobile company or a motorcycle
company or an engine company as I was
taught in grad school but now as a
mobility company and that's an important
distinction we aren't simply thinking
about how to preserve our current
business model which centers around
gasoline-powered cars and motorcycles
instead we're thinking about what we can
do to advance human mobility in all of
its forms and in the process ensure the
sustainability of our own business
second for a business to not only
survive but to truly thrive
products must bring real joy to the
customer the freedom and joy of mobility
that means everything we do is focus
first and foremost on the customer and
creating new value for their lives in
the old fuels arena this means making an
emotional connection between the
customer and the car regardless of
what's under the hood or in the trunk
it's not enough to make a product for
the environment because the environment
doesn't buy and use the cars people do
and finally with the cement a sincere
commitment to sustainability we want to
bring technologies to the market while
minimizing any impact our products and
our operations will have on the
environment that sustains us realizing
this vision with a more sustainable low
co2 future is a very different kind of
challenge than our previous efforts on
air quality first of all climate change
is not a local or even just the national
issue but a global concern co2 emissions
in their impact to the environment
recognize no Geographic political or
social boundaries and the emissions
themselves are on a totally different
scale we're a modern automobile may emit
only 10 or 20 pounds of smog-forming
emissions in its lifetime that same car
will produce upwards of 150 thousand
pounds of co2 almost one pound for every
mile it travels the challenge then is to
improve fuel efficiency at the same time
as we work to affect the transition away
from carbon-based fuels this will
require fundamental shifts in technology
and powertrain technology of course but
also in the infrastructure of how we
produce distribute and consume energy in
our cars and our homes and our factories
and our offices further the most
effective solutions will involve the
coordinated efforts of many stakeholders
across a broad range of endeavors
including also automakers but also
scientists and engineers in a wide
variety of fields as well as energy
companies policymakers NGOs and of
course academia
for our part we're working diligently to
address both the vehicle and
infrastructure side of the alt fuel
equation on the vehicle side Honda is
pursuing what we call a portfolio
approach that encompasses virtually all
of the most promising technology
solutions everything from hybrids and
battery v's to natural gas and fuel cell
electric vehicles and as I alluded to
earlier soon plug-in hybrids this is
anything but a cover all your best
strategy though rather its recognition
that there's no silver bullet technology
or a single approach to realizing the
move away from fossil fuels it's also
about ensuring the sustainability of our
own business by developing core
technology know how we're building the
foundation of our future value creation
and ensuring that we can continue to
bring new joy to our customers and based
on this portfolio concept Honda's been
building its engineering and marketing
know-how in a deliberate step-by-step
way always with an emphasis on the real
world deployments and a determined focus
on the satisfaction of the customer and
this is key especially when you're
talking about new and largely unproven
technologies whose focus and whose
future depends on a great deal on making
a very good first impression right now
Honda is looking to make some great
first impressions with a whole new range
of powertrain technologies that were
marketing under the rubric of earth
dreams technology this is a broad scope
of technologies that will power our
vehicles today and tomorrow once again
covering everything for more efficient
engines new hybrid technologies to more
advanced electromotive systems at the
base of the pyramid or a family of new
gasoline engines using a myriad of new
combustion and friction reducing
technologies these new direct engine
direct injection engines are seeing
their first application in the u.s. in
our all-new Accord which just went on
sale
more than a month ago in the
four-cylinder range this includes an
all-new direct-injected engine with VTEC
variable valve timing mated to an
all-new continuously variable
transmission that delivers great
performance and top fuel economy CVT
transmissions are more efficient you
lose a lot of energy and shifting gears
yesterday at the LA Auto Show we in
veiled our first v6 direct injected
engine in the all new flagship sedan of
our luxury brand the 2014 Acura RLX
building these new powertrains required
a multi-million dollar investment in new
manufacturing technology at our engine
and transmission plants in Ohio these
investments reflect the incredible
competition that exists today and the
race for fuel economy bragging rights
but they also speak to our understanding
that the gasoline internal combustion
engine will remain a significant and
perhaps even dominant part of the
powertrain mix for many years or even
decades to come whether paired with
electric motors and hybrid systems or as
freestanding power plants continued
advances in internal combustion engine
technology and fuel efficiency will be
critically important for the near term
in fact as we continue to improve IC
engine efficiency and there's still a
great deal of room for further gains
gasoline engines will become an even
tougher competitor for alternative
systems diesel engines are part of the
picture as well and we've got new
cleaner and more efficient diesel
technology that we're launching now in
Europe and in India but the market for
diesel engines here in the US remains
quite small in part because of the high
cost of diesel fuel and the lingering
bad reputation of the domestic
automakers diesel programs in the late
70s so those of you that pumped leaded
gas probably remember some of those
frankly speaking it's going to take our
generation and older to die off before
the diesel stands a real comeback in
America
if question why do you think it managed
quicker to overcome that bad reputation
there you know I think some of it is
that the manufacturers there had
reliable engine products so here on top
of the polluting aspect of it the
European manufacturers had better
technology so you didn't have the
reliability issues next come hybrids and
plug-in hybrids which in the interest of
time I'm going to tackle together
expanded use of hybrid technology paired
with more efficient engines is really at
the heart of honda's efforts to reduce
co2 emissions in the near to mid-term
hybrids offer high levels of utility
good performance and convenience you can
fill up at any gas station and in the
case of strong hybrid systems some
unique values like quiet and responsive
electric motor only operation like our
new accord plug-in hybrid and they have
a good or at least well understood
reputation in the marketplace if you've
ever driven an electric car you'll find
it's a kick the torque from electric
motors much greater than you'd have with
a smaller internal combustion engine car
you don't have that gutless feeling the
acceleration strong and the fuel economy
is good even better than with IC engines
the market for hybrid vehicles really
illustrates the challenge of moving a
technology from fundamental viability to
mass market availability I'm talking
here about cars like our own insight or
cr-z sporty hybrid and the civic hybrid
as well as the growing family of prius
vehicles that Toyota makes and
hybridized versions of other popular
cars like Ford's fusion and Hyundai's
elantra these are very mainstream
vehicles with a great share of mind and
yet despite their very practical
capabilities and a dozen years of
concerted marketing efforts across the
entire industry hybrids still represent
roughly
four percent of us light-duty vehicle
sales and frankly you can see an
increasing number of these vehicles sold
as fleets and serving as taxicabs among
other uses so the adoption isn't that
great in addition to the need for
increased utility that comes with
typical mass-market sedans the single
biggest turtle to broader market
acceptance is the technology costs
versus the fuel economy benefit it's
that break-even point on your additional
investment is a consumer as well as
concerns for long-term durability and
resale value the replacement battery can
be very expensive at midlife and for
plug-in hybrids recharging
infrastructure remains a significant
additional drawback I know I'm beginning
to sound a little negative on hybrid
technology but that's not my intention
if we didn't see the potential we
wouldn't be making big investments like
we are today at Honda we hope to further
move the needle on the hybrid value
equation with a series of new hybrid
systems for small midsize and larger
vehicles I already mentioned the new to
motor system and our soon to be
announced or announced today accord
plug-in hybrid we provided new details
at the LA auto show this morning with
the announcement that it will achieve an
epa highway fuel economy rating of 115
MPGe in electric driving mode that's the
highest fuel economy rating of any
plug-in hybrid in America the plug-in
accord will be joined later next year by
an accord hybrid model using the same
basic to motor system minus a plug-in
capability and achieving 47 miles per
gallon overall later Nick yes how long
it coloring is the electric range so
it's not about 15 miles in electrical
lifting later next year we're going to
introduce a 3 motor system when we call
this
sport hybrid super handling all-wheel
drive in the acura rlx i know that's a
mouthful as I've just demonstrated but
it gives you a pretty good indication of
what this new system is intended to
achieve the RLX will have three electric
motors one each to power the rear wheels
and a third motor integrated with a
7-speed dual-clutch transmission that
together produce 90 horsepower and
enable independent control of torque
output at the wheels for a new level of
handling performance along with the fuel
economy of 30 30 30 or 30 miles per
gallon the city highway and combined now
how that works the super handling
all-wheel drive system today uses an
accelerator gear to speed up the outer
wheel to help you around a turn in the
future we'll do that electrically a
third single motor system with the focus
on affordability will be deployed in
smaller vehicles like the honda fit in
the near future but it retains the
commitment to provide both fuel economy
and fund the drive performance at a very
high level taken together we hope these
new three new hybrid systems will
further expand the appeal and reach of
our hybrid vehicles with Honda and Acura
customers around the world one step
further down the road to electrification
is the battery electric vehicle based on
the u.s. electricity grid well two-wheel
greenhouse gas emissions are roughly in
the same basket maybe a little bit more
than the most efficient hybrid vehicles
and what I mean by well to wheel is when
you plug in an electric car you have to
think about how that electron was
generated and depending on where you
plug in in Ohio or Washington State it's
very different when you take into
account the move to less
carbon-intensive energy production here
in the US the picture gets much better
in the past year alone the US grid has
cut its carbon intensity by about ten
percent that's enormous
based on the move away from coal to
compress natural gas and other sources
in California fit v's well to wheel co2
emissions are roughly 100 grams per mile
about half that of a simile similarly
sized hybrid car this is great promise
in electric vehicles our new Fit EV is
based on the popular 5 door 5 passenger
honda fit subcompact platform which is
one of our highest volume global models
Stanford's played an important role in
this effort as one of three partners in
our Honda electric vehicle demonstration
program which we set up to continue to
conduct ongoing research on the
challenge of achieving broader
acceptance of electric vehicles the Fit
EV is also a great example of how our
portfolio approach is paying dividends
in the real world performance and value
of our products in the hands of
customers with 118 miles per gallon
equivalent the Fit EV has the highest
epa fuel economy rating of any
mass-produced electric vehicle I know
that's beginning to sound like a
familiar refrain and that includes an
industry-leading energy consumption
rating of 29 kilowatt hours per 100
miles and top class driving range of 82
miles with its onboard charging system
the Fit EV also boasts the fastest
recharging times at less than three
hours when connected to a 240 volt
circuit this is achieved through more
efficient motors smarter bad battery
management and improve regenerative
braking capacity I want you to pay
careful attention to this one this is
important
for starters the fit EV has a new
electro servo brake system that is a
further evolution of the system we
developed in our FCX Clarity fuel cell
electric vehicle the system uses
advanced cooperative control between the
brakes and electric powertrain to
achieve an eight percent increase in
energy recovery during braking compared
with other systems on the market
incidentally we're using the same system
in the new accord plug-in and that's how
we get the extra range and the fit V's
92 kilowatt synchronous permanent magnet
motor also borrows heavily from the FCX
clarity and achieves a ninety four point
six percent efficiency rate in the epa
city test cycles I don't know if anyone
here has had the opportunity to drive a
fit EV but virtually everyone who has
remarks about how incredibly fun it is
as I said before electric vehicles are
fun as a as proud as we are of what
we've achieved with respect to
efficiency range and recharging
performance we're equally proud of the
fits fund the drive nature which is an
important part of our approach to the
joy of mobility it's also a very
important part of Hans of honda's DNA I
said before environments excuse me
environments don't buy cars people do we
launched the Fit EV this past August
through select dealers in California and
Oregon the maps don't show up I
apologize our marketing approach is a
three-year 389 dollar month clothes then
lease that includes insurance and
maintenance we plan to expand the
program to six East Coast markets
beginning next year now we've taken some
criticized criticism in the friends for
this approach which some feel is too
conservative especially for a car that's
good and which some have even labeled it
as a compliance car designed primarily
around California
mandate the last one is really a red
herring all you have to do is drive the
car experience its refinement and sporty
handling to realize the target wasn't
simply to meet a regulatory requirement
we could have easily build cars and just
put them out there but I want to be
clear about one point and our view
retail leasing is not only the smart way
to market EV technology it's really the
optimal approach and the best strategy
to ensure that we create that kind of
thanks a lot that positive customer
experience that I said before was so
important in the early stages of
introducing these new types of
technologies now it's tempting to take a
look at the challenge of introducing
alternative fuel vehicles as simply an
issue of technology but based on our
experience introducing the electric
vehicle the EV + more than 15 years ago
and for generations of natural
gas-powered Civic sedans we have a great
deal of experience and how to foster
good customer attitudes toward adopting
new technologies in fact we probably
have more marketing expertise in the
alternative fuel arena than anyone else
in this industry and you don't have to
look too far to understand how other
automakers more aggressive hands-off
approach create some early challenges
with respect to customers attitudes and
confidence in the durability and value
of EV technology as some people whose
job it is the foster good experiences
and a good image for old fuel vehicles
these are not frankly positive
developments finally there's the
hydrogen fuel cell electric vehicle fuel
cell cars are kind of like the b-list
celebrities of the old fuel world one
minute in the spotlight and next almost
completely ignored we feel it's the
ultimate solution in recent years the US
government's taken a rather dim view of
the potential of this technology but in
just the past six months we've seen a
renewed interest on the part of the do
II and others in the future of fuel
cells and
it's heartening because while it's
absolutely wonderful for anyone to
advocate strongly on behalf of a
particular technology what we don't want
to see and frankly it's very dangerous
for regulators and other influential
leaders to try to pick winners and
losers among the competing technologies
at this stage of the game even before
the race has been run let's see the
goals but let's not dictate the
solutions in the marketplace honda for
its part remains optimistic about the
long-term potential of fuel cell
vehicles as the ultimate solution as i
just said to our energy and
environmental concerns and we have
invested consistently in the advancement
and real-world deployment of our fuel
cell technology previous FCX models have
broken through some major technical
barriers including cold weather
performance and the packaging of the
fuel cell stack and our FCX Clarity is
the first fuel cell vehicle to package
its powertrain and a stylish four-door
sedan and with performance that's
virtually on a par with a conventional
gasoline-powered car we've releasing the
clarity on a limited basis to customers
in Southern California during July of
2008 that's my plan to introduce the
clarity to the bay area come next year
hydrogen fuel cell vehicles give us a
pathway to operate small medium and
large vehicles on a renewable carbon
free fuel refuel the vehicle in three
minutes drive 300 miles between
refueling and three years from now in
2015 we plan to introduce an all-new
fuel cell car that showcases further
advancements in Honda fuel cell
technology particularly with respect to
the cost in addition the hydrogen
another means of storing renewable solar
energy and a chemical means is bio
ethanol we're engaged in a multi-year rd
program with the National Renewable
Energy Lab to study more efficient means
of producing by an effort by an ethanol
from corn stover the wastes this could
be used in internal combustion engine
vehicles such as our flex fuel Civic
that we sell in Brazil or in different
kind of fuel cell electric vehicle a bio
ethanol powered fuel cell car would
operate much like a hydrogen-powered fcv
with zero smog-forming tailpipe
emissions but with a higher energy
density and better fuel distribution and
storage characteristics than hydrogen
for electric vehicles of all kinds
driving the cost down is critical and
for battery v's increasing range to
improve battery technologies equally
important every automaker including
honda is very guarded when it comes to
discussing costs we're operating in a
highly competitive environment and
there's no one who will tell you with a
straight face at least that they found
the secret formula for financially
sustainable high production volume sales
of electric vehicles even if we take a
very optimistic view on battery
technology which assumes a doubling of
energy density and having the cost in
the next ten years we're still not
within spitting distance of the gasoline
internal combustion engine in terms of
energy density so there's still a lot of
work to be done now so far we've talked
almost exclusively about the vehicle
piece of the puzzle but that's only half
of a chicken and chicken feed exchange
of expanding old fuel vehicle
deployments the other big piece of
course is infrastructure which
encompasses a whole range of things
including strategic expansion of
recharging or refueling networks but
also smart vehicles and smart
infrastructure roads homes and utility
grids that Honda were keenly aware of
the need for parallel advancements in
both the powertrain technology and
infrastructure solutions as well as
means of mitigating the additional
strain that Eevee's can place on an
already stressed electric grid one
really unique concept is what we call
the Honda smart home system which honda
has initiated with community partners in
the Saitama
in Japan the HS HS as we call it is
installed in this demonstration test
house because it smartly integrates a
number of technologies to realize a
major reduction in the co2 footprint of
a typical household this includes
Honda's own cigs thin-film solar panels
a rechargeable home battery unit
electricity and hot water supply co
generating unit and what we call the
smart emix manager which is an energy
management device that optimally
controls electricity supplied from the
grid and energy generated by each device
in the system at the house remember that
power outage scenario I laid out at the
onset of my talk smart emix manager
reduces co2 emissions from the home and
at the same time provides a backup
supply of electricity so that the house
can be self-sufficient in the event of a
power outage through this demonstration
program we hope to realize a fifty
percent reduction in co2 emissions from
a typical household for now this is a
japan-only endeavor but it's something
we are taking a close look at here in
the US as well another example of
honda's effort is a new concept called
the Green Wave system which has the
potential to further improve energy
efficiency by helping the driver
maintain optimal speed to reduce the
need for traffic light stops think about
that isn't that one of the most annoying
things when you're driving it utilizes
vehicle infrastructure communication
incorporating data transmitted from
traffic signals and in testing in Japan
it showed up that a seven percent
improvement in fuel economy was
achievable by simply achieving a
smoother driving pattern without all of
that stop and go and believe me with an
annual expenditure on rd of five percent
of our annual revenue there isn't
anything in the realm of mobility that
we aren't working on
these kinds of innovative approaches
down for structure development married
to more efficient low co2 vehicle
technologies have the potential to
transform our way of life and preserve
it in the process but we can't affect
this kind of wholesale shift and
technology adoption and consumer
behavior all on our own government
entities in local state national levels
all have a critically important role to
play and helping create an environment
for these new technologies to take root
and to grow and it's not enough to
simply mandate asset sales of
alternative fuel vehicles without
accompanying actions to spur market
demand in particular the refueling and
recharging infrastructure that will make
the purchase of a natural gas plug-in or
electric vehicle a reasonable and
rational choice for a broader swath of
the driving public as any formal will
tell you you don't plant the seed before
you've tilled and nurtured the soil even
the most fertile plant won't bear fruit
if it's sewn and fallow earth it took us
a hundred years to build up the
infrastructure for gasoline-powered cars
but we don't have a hundred years to do
the same thing for the next generation
of technologies but at Honda we're
taught to always go forward with a
challenging spirit and a sense of
optimism and so I want to leave you with
some nice change image of how this might
all come together someday and then that
to this in the future so it's Monday
morning in my neck of the woods and this
poor guy let's call him Charlie leaving
his home in Orange County headed for an
8am meeting in Santa Monica it's really
bad to be Charlie right now you'd have
to leave around 530am the cover the 57
miles on the gridlock 405 but there was
a power outage in the middle of the
night and it screwed up his alarm clock
and now he's running late and the make
matters worse
Charlie forgot to stop for gas last
night so somewhere along the way he's
going to have to hit a gas station and
it speeds averaging seven miles an hour
bumper-to-bumper traffic cueing lights
to reenter the freeway the guy is
gripping the wheel so hard he starts to
sweat then he makes a potentially fatal
mistake of looking down at his phone and
bam he rear end someone that's what
passes for America's love affair with
the car on most days in Southern
California and I know it's not much
different up here in the Bay Area
because I've lived here as well but
maybe there's a better way let's rewind
the clock Charlie sally sally has a
plug-in accord that when she pulled into
the garage last night reminded her and
needed a charge Sally smart once plugged
in the car in the grid of a conversation
and decide the optimal time to make sure
you have a full charge when she leaves
the next morning while minimizing the
co2 emissions and strain on the grid
there's still a power outage but the
Honda smart home covers the gap so she
doesn't wake up late there's no powered
off DVR that failed to record last
night's episode of the walking dead
everything's wonderful so Sally jumps in
the car with plenty of juice to get to
her 8 30 meeting and navigates onto the
freeway but at this point having told
the cards intended destination she lets
go of the wheel sits back and catches up
on some email all the while the car is
taking in data from both the
infrastructure and other vehicles on the
road to guide it safely and efficiently
to its destination traffic moves along
at a brisk pace there's no accidents and
suddenly Sally fine she's got time to
kill time to make a pit stop but not for
gas and now thanks to Sally smart car
and smart infrastructure she gets to be
the hero shows up 15 minutes early for
that Monday morning meeting with a
couple of dozen randy's donuts in hand
and now if that isn't the freedom and
joy of no mobility I don't know what is
thanks a lot for your time this
afternoon okay Richard so if you don't
mind I'd like to ask a question to start
and what I'd really like to ask is about
your role honda has all of these
different things going on in R&D and
different kinds of business areas
developing new businesses how do you
keep up with all of this I spend a lot
of time meeting people I've been with
the company 20 years and I've had a
blind spot in 2 r.d because I spent all
my career in sales and marketing so I
would see the products when they're
ready to come to market so one of the
advisors in our group has been with the
company for quite a long time and he's
introduced the engineers on our team in
the marketing people to all the
different rd groups we see what they're
working on and we explore what's in the
marketplace and peer down the silos in
the company you see what's there to pull
out and bring it to public okay thanks
let's open the floor go ahead what are
the major pain points for designing a
hybrid drivetrain well a lot of it has
to do with the packaging because most of
the hybrids on the market weren't
conceived as hybrids so they're already
something else so where do you put the
battery so if you look at especially
some of the plugins that need larger
batteries you'll see the trunks starting
to disappear and we're putting the
batteries between the wheel towers in
the back which is a good place for them
so I think packaging is one of them wait
battery flies in the face of what
engineers want to do is strip weight out
of the car and then of course there's
cost because a hybrid car is both an
electric car and the internal combustion
engine car so the performance has to be
there
okay go ahead I saw a couple of your
slides you had pictures of planes I was
wondering if you could comment at all
images sorts popping your fuel supply oh
it's a good question we have established
a new company in the southeast a few
years ago called hondajet and we're in
the final stages of receiving FAA
approval for the fuselage and the
engines and it's a carbon fiber fuselage
so it's a lot lighter and stronger and
we developed a unique engine mounting
system that puts the engine on top of
the wing and all of this drives
increased fuel efficiency and it's the
most fuel-efficient jet in its class it
runs i Jes you ok but I noticed the
airlines are starting to use blends
united airlines which i fly on a lot is
making a big deal about some of their
blended fuels but in a little while fuel
in the middle of the regular jet fuel
but one of the challenges that when you
change the mix in the in the fuel is the
materials in the engines so you have to
be careful and you can't reduce the
durability so you have engines that have
been on the market and this is a big
debate about eat n Andy 15 and even
greater mixes of ethanol you have a lot
of cars that have been on the road for
10 or 15 years that weren't designed for
those types of fuels and if you start to
use those fuels in them you're going to
damage the engines so you have to have a
transition in both the engine technology
and the fuel delivery and that's another
challenge when I was when I first got my
license they went to the unleaded fuel
and gas stations didn't have enough
pumps for all these different fuels used
to have low medium and high then they
had unleaded they had diesel back then
so there's distribution challenges as
well I saw your hand next if you look at
the note records and cities in San
Francisco Los Angeles especially a
ravaging Tokyo and so on
what would you say somebody said the
solution of the future is not different
kinds of power sauce because the jet
cars is not a question if you have
electric cars or internal combustion
engines is simply too many cars out
there can generate the solution for the
future is more public transportation
it's changing people minds moving along
/ or in just a public transportation
different words walking so it's actually
not the array of different different
power sources for the car until changing
people miles will public transportation
and so on because simply too many cars
out there are we have to get away from
the car at all to make cities like
Eugene Los Angeles even liberal in the
future for the plug-in us I think
something that hand is supported for a
long time car sharing efforts and they
have to reduce the congestion you still
need cars and the city's end and mass
transit can't be everywhere because then
it's going to deliver the same
congestion as the individual autos do so
it's a blend of the two car sharing is
important for that there are companies
in Europe that are pretty advanced in
that area and I know you're going to see
a lot of that coming to the u.s. very
soon but that's certainly one of those
government questions write a policy
question what do you really you know
push for the regulation side right yeah
okay go ahead so as a poor grad student
haven't been in the market for a new car
for a ever comes the last the last thing
I remember hearing a Prius civil and the
different commands was that there was
extremely high demand but not enough
supply and so when you mentioned that
currently hybrid sales negative about
four percent of sales us I was wondering
if that may be due to the fact there's
not a hybrid able I think it has to do
more with what a hybrid delivers so
hybrid delivers better fuel economy in
what would be the city driving or the
put a bump or driving because you're
running on the battery you're not
accelerating the engine as much so in a
lot of places in the in the country city
driving in particular that's why the
taxi fleets are adopting them you also
have I would say some twisted efforts
for whatever reason to stimulate hybrid
sales by allowing them to use the
carpool lanes which were originally
developed for congestion now you fill
them up with hybrids because they want
to stimulate the sale of the hybrids so
carpool lanes are in places like this
and they're in the south and they're in
the Northeast Corridor they're not in
Kansas there's no bumper to bumper
traffic in Kansas so I think you see
very high penetration rates and some of
these congested metros or in states that
are stimulating the demand and not
elsewhere can I ask a follow-up what the
has been honda announced up a suggested
retail price for the new accord plug-in
hybrid i believe we did 39,000 back the
standard version of a regular gasoline
powered Accord at this point there'll be
a hybrid also coming in the spring but
now they're all internal combustion and
I really wouldn't know but it's several
thousand dollars yeah I remember a few
years ago looking around and seeing
about a five-thousand-dollar price
difference between regular hybrids and
and gasoline powered versions of the
same car and battery and the higher
motor right so the economics are tough
right so you have to do a lot of city
driving to benefit from that improved
low-speed fuel economy and taxis do a
lot of that some consumers don't but if
you get a carpool lane sticker maybe
that's good enough for you and you don't
care so I think a lot of people bought
hybrids really in one hybrid state it's
one of the fast lane no okay go ahead
now that big oil is so proud to give us
our natural gas back and that we're not
going to have any deficits it's going to
think what's that going to do to the
introduction of your clarity to the rate
that comes into the market if there's no
role in setting for anybody to bring
hydrogen to copy well I think you have
to continue to push towards the future
because fuel prices petrol prices will
continue to go up and they have
consistently they go up they go down but
the long-term trend is up hydrogen can
be manufactured in factories and
distributed in different ways so perhaps
there is a cost opportunity there
long-term if not there's the
environmental impact of hydrogen I think
that's probably the most important when
you think about the world 100 years from
now i'm steve i'm curious about Honda's
presence in China I was wondering what
kind of government regulation is there
at the auto industry in China and when
you shift vehicles there my
understanding is that the Chinese
emission standards are actually lower
than those in the US and Europe so our
honda vehicles that are sold they're
comparable to say a california vehicle
or is it when outside china is a whole
different kettle of fish first of all we
don't we ship acuras there and i'm not
sure what the emission standards are
there and they have different classes of
vehicles but they're virtually the same
accurate that we we sell here over there
we manufacture a licensed vehicles in
some cases and we've introduced a local
brand as well of local vehicles they
have different standards and I think
they would be wise to increase both
their fuel efficiency and their
environmental regulations as quickly as
possible you know if you remember when
they had the Olympics they're all those
stories about them shutting industries
down for a month before to clear the air
in Beijing in another city so given the
sheer density and scale of China
they need to get with it okay go ahead
how long this fella and you'd mentioned
that the days challenge for electric
vehicles is the cost and you are going
to share any of the cost for electric
vehicle however can you share with us
the cost of the engine drivetrain since
that's target you need to be competitive
with it dazzling only was it cost today
at least there's two campania there's
two components the cost the first is
really the difference in materials which
is significant because you're adding an
electric motor or two electric motors to
an engine and then there's the battery
but the real issue is scale so if you
take an accord and let's say we build
350,000 of those here and maybe five
percent of them are plug-in or a hybrid
so you can see you don't have the scale
lab or ties those differences over so
that's really where a lot of the cost
comes from I couldn't even give you
specifics because I don't know but the
biggest factor is volume and whether you
build one car or a million the getting
in cost is just about the same and it's
steep I was just going to bring that
back sounds like a chicken and egg
problem in terms of the price people
won't buy them visit to expenses so you
don't make as many so it's more
expensive so how do you get out of that
cycle take a huge loss and you make it
up elsewhere back in the back natural
gas is getting lot shipper these days I
things go to last ten years oh dear i'm
just gonna need you try the best happy
with before
we certainly are in fact my boss is
pushing me over the place about it
because more responsibilities is for the
sales of the natural gas Civic and I
think that's a perfect example of a very
easy transition for an automaker because
you're using an internal combustion
engine the gas is going to remain
available and add a much lower price
than petrol for a lot of different
reasons we don't have to get into here
but you don't have the distribution of
the fuel so we've had I think I said
four or five generations of natural gas
Civic sedans these cars are bulletproof
they don't give us or the consumers any
trouble you don't have fuel in many
states and there are a lot of companies
right now I spend a lot of time working
with venture capital companies that are
looking to set up compressed natural gas
distribution in many different business
models and I think they're cleaner
they're not zero carbon but they're a
lot cleaner and they're less expensive
to run you can even refuel at home with
it if you own a home and you have gas in
your in your home so I think that one's
very promising although the big
challenge they are again is cost and
scale but for consumer to have forty
percent off the price of fuel you can
make that back pretty quickly in the
heavy trucking business the fleet's and
you see in a lot of cities the buses
have gone the natural gas because the
more fuel you use the quicker you'll
break even on that investment and also
the engines last longer because it's a
cleaner-burning fuel so this is an area
where the Japan market developed in a
different direction than the u.s.
because taxis running on natural gas
have been a real kind of standard in
Japan for a long time yeah but you know
how can an automobile company convince
people to build out the infrastructure
and the smart home is a good example of
that too you know I spend a lot of time
with these ventures
yes and encouraging them they all want
to know where they're going to be cars
and again it's a chicken and egg thing
so we can take a loss on the car
someone's got to take a loss on the fuel
and the same things going on now with
hydrogen so there's a couple of hydrogen
stations in Southern California there's
a hydrogen station up here that either
exists or is about to but you you spend
a fortune to establish that station and
a car shows up every three days and
that's the problem so we're all going to
be building fuel cell cars the
government's pretty much said you need
to have these things and we've got a lot
of expertise in that and we're ready to
go but again if you don't have the
fueling the customers are going to be
frustrated and I don't know how far
you're willing to drive for fuel but
when you have three brands at every
intersection of petrol it's probably not
too far out of your way and that's going
to be one of the biggest challenges and
I think the government's done a pretty
good job of pushing the automaker's
around on this we also need the
encouragement for the infrastructure
because it isn't going to succeed
without it and natural gas exists under
any street that matters in the u.s.
right there's all gas pipes so all you
need is a compressor and a storage tank
and you can have natural gas fueling
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe but you really can't find
it anywhere so it has to be manufactured
and distributed it's always attached to
something else so your belief and the
ultimate kind of winning out of the fuel
cell of car is do you think it's because
of the way zero emission is defined I
mean what a fuel cell car actually have
less zero emission than a purely battery
electric vehicle it depends again where
the core energy comes from so if you
take a fuel cell car if it's a hydrogen
fuel cell car and you use electrolysis
to break water up and the energy comes
from solar panels then the
most pollution or carbon based pollution
you have in any of that is what it took
to make the solar panel solar panel last
year 30-plus years so that's a pretty
durable product electricity if you're
plugging your car in in San Onofre and
that was a you know a nuclear generated
electron no carbon no pollution but then
again you have to be concerned about
what you do with the fuel at the end of
the life so that's what i said earlier
when i meant they want to I'm nth when I
said well two wheel if you really think
about it all the way so hydrogen from
water is probably the ultimate because
you can make it from a solar panel or
you can make it from the grid but if the
grids in Ohio and it's coal power it's
not a real clean narrow about it so you
have to really think about it okay go
ahead fuel cells us the like ultimate
flagship but what if you do you see that
if you have major breakthroughs and
battery technology or some other
charging such as more dynamic charging
of electric vehicles that that would be
like the ultimate solution instead of
perpetual motion would be no doubt your
approach that you have to feed in some
energy and that was my point earlier in
that no one especially the government
shouldn't pick winners and losers at
this stage of the race we don't know and
by everybody competing competitions a
great thing by everyone competing and
experimenting with these things we're
going to find the breakthroughs you all
know from spending kinds and labs you
you don't find those things laying on
tables it takes long hours and maybe a
hundred tries before you get anything I
saw your hand first circles other direct
trains and where do you see that going
very small cars you mean you know it
depends where you are I think the the
lighter and smaller the vehicle you can
get away with a lot more and you can
probably have electric vehicles that
serve those purposes just fine you don't
have the rain
issues comfort and size and long
distance you probably want other kinds
of cars so we have we're very lucky in
that we run the range of mobility from
motorcycles up and depending on where
you are in the world is different
preferences depending on where you are
in the country so I think all of those
are possible we're building a new
factory in Mexico for the next
generation of our fit so that'll be an
entirely new car and there'll be some
variants probably with that to satisfy
those kinds of needs you had one slide
about nobility and joy and freedom on
that slide down at the bottom where some
pictures of some things other than
automobiles would you mention a little
bit about my design I'll take it in some
of these areas one was a robot robot
robot right it's pricey mo are you
familiar with hacia at all ok so asimo
is mobility but I C Mo's mobility for
people who can't really walk or take
care of themselves so if you're
homebound and you need an assistant or a
helper hicimos meant to provide that
kind of assistance by getting you things
and asimo is not a very tall person and
the reason for that is we've done
extensive research with robotics and
there's a museum there we go yeah so
there's a museum in at one of honda's
headquarters with all of the iterations
and evolutions of asimo and the very
first robots were like 9 feet tall and
they're scary to stand next to and what
we found is that our CMO needed to be at
eye level height with someone who's
sitting so that's the reason for a C
Mo's stature some of these other things
so this is this is meant to provide
strength when you're kneeling or sitting
and we have used those in our
manufacturing facilities so
a lot of jobs require crouching and
bending and that can be very painful and
destructive to your knees over time so
this is meant to support you while
you're working and this one here that
looks kind of like a boom box is I think
it's called you you 3x and if you go on
youtube you'll see a video of me writing
that in Japan and that has gyros in and
it balances itself you sit on this and
it has technology similar to the way a
Segway might work and you just sit on it
and you lean forward a little and you go
but the unique thing about it is you can
go sideways you don't have to turn you
just lean to the side and it goes
sideways so that might be good for an
indoor facility where you have a long
distance to go it has a very small
footprint for something like that yeah
it's meant to carry so what happens is
these this is what you sit on and they
fold down and it becomes another black
circle and there's a handle and you can
carry it so these are all the things we
experiment on there's other things which
you don't see here there's a device
called walking assist which is an
exoskeleton which is meant to help
people who have impaired walking
abilities walk and what this does is
follow your lead but it adds the
strength that you don't have so if
you're a stroke victim or have a severe
injury but can still walk with great
difficulty this will make up for the
strength that you don't have I've seen
several hands why don't you go through
that's the HondaJet there see them guys
so we call it a horse 616 yeah on the
horizon over here no way no I think
Americans not in any numbers not to
mention that those would need a lot of
work to meet all the crash standards and
legs here I think that again i said
earlier every every place is different
and if you've been the tokyo and you've
been to some very crowded asian or
european cities that's where the smart
car comes from the same kind of
requirements congestion and space okay
go ahead just a comment on this a
chicken leg provider probably another
because I'm avoiding some of the
electric mobility project in Europe
especially in Germany we have the same
issue they are that are professors cars
coming in premium price of whatever
thirty percent more than the regular car
to just look at an electric theater so
the question is which of violence cars
and the solution they are small to have
a joint joint effort between the
companies are you saying you tend to
take a loss I guess it's just a solution
the company should take a loss then
probably will never take a take off
because we know why business multiple
companies it is no injury to have
forgiven a textbook you know text breaks
from them for the consumers for example
based in China Europe you can get this
car from almost ten percent or even
thirty percent of the car you know thank
us as a tax refund compiling the coop
for example you know feat free parking
results parking Protected vehicles and
so on and all the stuff that you're
going to love you to google they are
talking about and see that one quarter
of the parking lot is resolved for that
commuters for example there's free
charge there are a lot of cost they are
we got here up those type move in cities
where you go Tupac ecological free
charging I mean the transfer for the
parking swapping levels of China to head
here and I ask you this have to be if
George this is what I be this is Sun has
to be an all market allah jane people
minds is my point evaluation form yeah
the government needs to stimulate the
rest of it yeah because you know
companies can can bear losses at the
beginning and you always do when you're
introducing something but you can't do
it continuously and the market won't eat
what it doesn't want so you can't
legislate demand you stimulate someone
to make it you have to stimulate people
to buy it and you have to make the
environment rich for them to use it
that's where the carpool lane stickers
come from and things like that i'm not
against that entirely but they were
meant for congestion and now we're using
them for other things but i do want to
to remind people of one thing that you
mentioned it's great when the government
gives goals for people to meet but not
to pick winners and how to get out of it
you just don't know you know just don't
know the CV cc engine was a very good
example of that nobody thought it could
be achieved yeah but that you know the
clean air standards could be achieved
all the other car makers were saying we
can't do it meanwhile Honda comes up
with a solution if it was up to the
government lead all wear brown suits all
right with picking a winner based on all
non political decisions rather than
you're working i don't know i don't know
if that's it they just throwing money
around this and i said earlier that one
of the engineers of my group says you
need 100 seats the cf1 sprouts and i
think that's what the government is
doing because you can pick on them for
Sullinger on there's you know whenever
there's money there's politics and
there's corruption and that's what
happens but I think the government needs
to provide that kind of tilled soil
Steve I've got one more question we'll
finish up the formal part five years
from now how will you know how will you
measure the success that you've had with
the evdo well I think it would be in new
product introductions whether they be in
automobiles or other products okay that
sounds good we've got some refreshments
outside first of all please join me in
thanking Steve thank you thank you
you